the entire world needs a reset that just
needs a reset that's it there's a
critical moment right here and people
don't really grasp it because it's
moving slowly even though we can see
it's moving much quicker than we'd like
to do it's moving too slow for the great
percentage of people to even see it
they're more concerned with their
day-to-day lives and they are with year
to year lives in decade to decade they
are not concerned for their own
grandchildren
I remember when Obama was president and
he went over and they had a a world
summit about climate or something and I
thought this is a time for someone to
stand up and say we need to come
together everybody needs to come
together not one leader said that not
one leader took advantage of the fact
that we have a chance now and a common
goal to survive that should bring us all
together not one of our leaders said
that I started thinking well maybe I'm
out of my mind maybe that's not what
should happen but I really do feel that
way and Obama was he was a huge letdown
to me I mean I personally I don't think
he's done you know I don't really I
don't feel like oh he's great and Trump
sucks I don't feel that way you know I
know that Obama was more aligned with
the way I think but he didn't do
anything
no one stated the obvious they never
tried to bring no one tried the United
States from America didn't try to bring
the world together no one stood up and
said listen we need to put aside our
petty differences and really start to
try to save the world the time to do
something has been now for the last 50
years and no one's doing anything as it
matters for everybody every color of
human being every color of plant every
color of animal all of it all matters to
everyone and we just have to get a
little more focused on the fact that
we're not that different
as opposed to focusing on our
differences our we have a lot to fight
because our leadership is trying to make
us fight each other because that makes
us weaker so it's just a classic
situation and I hope that help that we
can reverse it soon because it's it's a
very dangerous situation